getting a report now from post my guys
opposed Millennial they're saying the
sites are back up they've got all the
information from the bombshell story
that resulted in a DDOS attack
post-millennial human event make sure
you go subscribe by the way to make sure
that we can fend off the next great
opportunity for a plug by the way all
right but yeah we pull up postmanial
quite a bit on the show and we have
Libyan quite a bit so what happened is
before the show I'm like you know let's
see what the post millennial is not
about and it wasn't working and then
Jack's like well we just put out these
big stories and sure enough but uh back
to uh Donald Trump I thought it was just
a resting point and yeah no it was too
big too big but uh Trump's gonna go
after Joe Biden so obviously you know
brand and I are in agreement Jack I'm
curious what you think
it's gone too far
you know it's it's really gone too far
at this point where you've got a
situation where this this and keep in
mind that it's it's not just if you
think it's just Joe Biden Hunter Biden
that are taking foreign money